[Music]
from the creator of your older sister's
favorite 80s movies and the Chris
Columbus that didn't kill any Indians
comes the Christmas classic that cable
channels have rerun every holiday season
for the last 20 years 20 god that makes
me feel old home alone
deck the halls and gather round for a
family film about standing your ground
in one of the most violent kids movies
ever made that's one part Ferris Bueller
and one parts aw
this Christmas travel to the all-white
part of Chicago to meet the
McCallister's the worst family ever
Kevin you're such a disease rejoice in
the Christmas spirit as they gang up on
this eight-year-old boy don't you know
how to knock slim wad you're completely
helpless
look what you did you little jerk
everyone's family eats me then stick him
in the Attic and leave the country
Kenny witness years of neglect and abuse
take their toll on the small child as he
shows all the signs of becoming a
sociopath like manipulation come talking
to himself I can't seem to find my
toothbrush shut up or go out today and
trapping two nonviolent criminals inside
a sadistic world of torture from which
there is no escape
[Music]
but gosh darnit if he isn't just the
cutest little thing me the Wet Bandits
there's more who sounds like he's the
narrator from The Wonder Years kids are
scared of the dark and hairy who sounds
like Joe Pesci trying not to curse in a
PG movie watch as these bumbling idiots
only robbed in broad daylight where
fingerless gloves during a burglary and
are irrationally obsessed with one house
that's the one love and that's the
Silverthorne that's really just full of
mannequins and poinsettias seriously
there's like nothing we're stealing here
so bundle up and relive the early 90s
joy of micromachines starting lineup
figures Johnny Carson 35 millimeter
cameras landline phones answering
machines three 911 air travel and
Macaulay Culkin
prepare to have your heartstrings tugged
as Kevin who's been home alone for three
days is finally reunited with his family
then immediately left alone again well
that was awkward
starring Joe Pepsi wish kid little big
beat Arcade Fire the dad from home alone
it be wets bed Jasper beard Lee John
cameo plus fee the running mom and Space
Jam home alone oh man
the seat always gets me I'm not crying
you're crying thanks for watching the
North remembers fort Garfunkel release
the Kraken shuck it Trebek she sells
seashells by the seashore a screen
junkies for more awesome stuff click
here to subscribe